. OK, let's go next to.
Wow, I'm shell shocked by that. Let's go to Will
from D.C.. Will from D.C.. You're on the air.
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Yes,
hi. I wanted to speak, I guess, about the
yeah, and sorry about you out right when you
said the key thing you want to speak about what?
The right wing media, OK? I think
we all have relatives who, you know,
they're they're afraid of things that we sort
of have difficulty comprehending, I guess. I
guess my question is with covid and a lot of
what's going on with the dangers of the virus
and climate change, and how much do you think that
the government is going to get better at, I guess,
lining what people are actually in danger from and
what their fears are, I guess, as when it comes to
right wing propaganda? I know that now it's Rush
Limbaugh's four horsemen of the apocalypse, with
science being one of them is something that's
out to get. With all the misinformation,
with covid and everything that's going on, do
you think that the government sort of in terms
of institutions and public awareness is going
to be a little more aggressive about trying to
insert themselves into that, into that
into that loop and try to subvert a lot
of this misinformation that's going on about now?
I mean, there are people who are more afraid that,
you know, antifa is going to hurt them than
they're going to die of heart disease in their
60s. And obviously, that's ridiculous.
So in other words, it's like we know
that people dramatically overstate how likely
they are to be victims of a terrorist attack,
but they dramatically understate how likely they
are, for example, to get into a car accident,
which is overwhelmingly more common.
Exactly. And I think that's one of
the government's main functions, is to is to
try to align our fears and from to what we're
actually in danger of being harmed by. Right.
I mean, listen, if if as a country and when I
say that, I don't mean just some people. If three
hundred and thirty million people all understood
the virus, for example, we would have way fewer
deaths because people would be cooperating.
If more people understood the risk from climate
change, we would not have the politicization that
we do as to what to do about climate change. I
completely agree with you. I don't know how you
change that narrative, because when you have such
a weaponized disinformation propaganda network of
of channels combined with educational issues,
combined with partizanship used to raise money,
I don't know how you start doing it, but I'm
completely on board with you as far as identifying
the problem that people misjudge the risks they
over and understate the risks in different areas
in ways that are counterproductive.
Absolutely. I guess. Do you think
the Biden administration is going to maybe
have government institutions that are more
proactive about public awareness about this?
I hope so. I mean, listen, their first big test
will be the virus. Foushee is going to be working
with Biden and he's bringing in a coronavirus sort
of chief or czar, Jeff Zients. I think his name
is. I forget his name. Exactly. And he's going
to ask for one hundred days of mask wearing and
he's going to oversee the vaccine distribution.
Let that that'll be the first test. Let's check in
and, you know, April 15th and see how it's going.
Absolutely. Well, thank you, I appreciate you
coming. My pleasure. Great to hear from you. A lot
of very interesting calls today at David Pakman
dotcom discord. Let's oh, this is interesting.